MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION IS
BLOCKING SHIPMENTS OF
SEMICONDUCTORS TO CHINESE TECH
GIANT HUAWEI AS THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY THREATENS TO
SANCTION SEVERAL U.S. LAWMAKERS
INCLUDING SENATOR TOM COTTON WHO
HAS APPEARED ON THIS PROGRAM TO
CALL OUT CHINA’S HANDLING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC AMONG
OTHER BAD BEHAVIOR.
GEORGIA CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS
JUST INTRODUCED HIS OWN
LEGISLATION ON CHINA HE JOINS ME
NOW.
CONGRESSMAN GOOD TO SEE YOU
THANKS FOR JOINING US LET’S GET
RIGHT TO IT.
YOUR BILL BASICALLY SANCTIONS
AND FREEZES ASSETS OF THE
CHINESE LEADERSHIP.
TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> EXACTLY, CHINA DECIDES THEY
WANT TO BE A WORLD ECONOMIC THEY
ALSO HAVE BEEN A RESPONSIBLE
WORLD ECONOMIC POWER THEY CAN’T
TREAT THE WORLD LIKE THEIR
CITIZEN WHICH IS IS TO KEEP THEM
UNDER OPPRESSION AND MAKE THEM
BELIEVE THEY HAVE A COMMUNIST
DOCTRINE AND WHAT WE’LL DO IS
SAY IF YOU WANT TO BE A PART OF
THE WORLD YOU NEED TO BE OUT
THERE AND GIVE US FULL
INTERNATIONAL ACCOUNTING OF WHAT
YOU D & D NOT DO IT HAS BECOME
VERY APPARENT THEY WERE MUCH
MORE WILLING TO CONTROL IT
INTERNALLY BUT YET SPREAD IT
ACROSS THE WORLD.
CHINA HAS A PROBLEM AND THE
PROBLEM IS THEY CAN’T BE
HONEST WITH THEMSELVES AND
HONEST WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY SO WE’RE GOING TO PUT
IT TO GIVE THE PRESIDENT A WAY
TO SANCTION AND NOT TIE HIS
HANDS BUT GIVE HIM EVERY TOOL IN
THE TOOL BOX TO GET THEM TO
COMPETE IN A WAY THAT IS FAIR IN
THE INTERNATIONAL MARKET AND IF
THEY DON’T THEN FINE THEY WILL
SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES FOR IT.
MARIA: DO YOU WORRY THAT THERE
WILL BE CONSEQUENCES TO THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO PUSHBACK.
YOU ALREADY HAVE CHINESE STATE
MEDIA THREATENING CONGRESSMEN.
YOU WEREN’T ON THE LIST BUT JOSH
HOLLY WAS ON THE LIST, TOM
COTTON WAS ON THE LIST THEY ARE
WATCHING EACH OF YOUR DISTRICTS
TO TRY TO GET BACK AT YOU FOR
COMING UP WITH LEGISLATION
AGAINST CHINA AND THE COMMUNIST
PARTY.
>> I HOPE THE COMMUNIST PARTY
IS WATCHING MY NAME IS DOUG, AND
I’M GOING TO STAND WITH AMERICA
AND I’M TIRED OF THEM TRYING TO
STEAL PHARMACEUTICALS AND TIRED
OF LETTING THEM THEIR OWN
COUNTRY BE LOCKED DOWN AND THEN
LIE TO IT TO THE WORLD.
THE COMMUNIST PARTY MUST REALIZE
THEY ARE TRYING TO KEEP THEIR
OWN PEOPLE BUT THAT REGIME IS
DESTINED TO FAIL.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE IF YOU’LL
HAVE AN ECONOMIC PARTNER IN THE
WORLD THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO COMPETE LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
DOES AND TELL THE TRUTH.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY CAN’T DO THAT
EVEN TO THEIR OWN PEOPLE SO WHY
WOULD WE EXPECT IT FROM THE REST
OF THE WORLD.
MARIA: LET ME SWITCH GEARS
CONGRESSMAN ASK YOU ABOUT THE
UNMASKING.
YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT’
RESPONSE TO WHAT HAS TAKEN PLACE
WHERE WE SEE A LEVEL OF OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS MOVING
TO TELL THE WORLD EXPOSE WHAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A PRIVATE
CALL BETWEEN
AN INCOMING NSA DIRECTOR AND THE
AMBASSADOR TO RUSSIA.
>> WELL IT’S AMAZING WHAT WE
SEEN.
MARIA WE’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR SO LONG AND NOW IT
FEELS LIKE WHAT WE’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT AND THE CORRUPT
WITH PETER STRZOK AND MCCABE AND
COMEY AND NOW YATES BUT NOW FIND
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
WE FIND IT IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
NOT THE OVAL OFFICE OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP BUT THE OVAL OFFICE OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO WAS ASKING
ABOUT FLYNN WHO WOULD ADD HIS
OWN CHIEF OF STAFF UNMASK HIM
THE DAY THERE WAS A MEETING AND
OH, BY THE WAY JOE BIDEN WERE
YOU ASLEEP IN THIS MEETING AS
WELL WHEN YOU ACTUALLY WERE
THERE AND YOU TOLD JUST THIS
PAST WEEK THAT YOU KNEW
NOTHING ABOUT CUPPERTINO AND YOU
ACTUALLY MADE A REQUEST FOR
UNMASKING?
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WE’RE SEEING
IS PEOPLE ARE WAKING UP TO THE
REAL FACT THERE WAS AN  ATTEMPT
TO TAKE OUT A CANDIDATE AND THEN
A PRESIDENT BEFORE HE COULD GET
GOING, AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SHOULD BE DEMANDING WHY
EVERY NEWS OUTLET IS NOT COVER
ING THIS THE WAY YOU HAVE
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS AND
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN SCREAMING
AT THE TOP OF OUR LUNGS THERE
WAS BASICALLY A COO ATTEMPT AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL AND NOW WE ARE
RIGHT INTO THE OVAL OFFICE.
MARIA: AND YOU STILL DON’T SEE
IT ON ANY OF THE NEWS MEDIA,
THEY ACTUALLY USED THE MEDIA TO
LEAK THINGS, CLASSIFY DOCUMENTS
IN FACT, TREY GOWDY SAID THAT
LEAKING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IS
A 10 YEAR FELONY.
I KNOW WE’RE WAITING ON JOHN
DURHAM BUT DO YOU SEE CRIMES
BEING COMMITTED IN PLAIN SIGHT
HERE?
>> HOW COULD IT NOT BE?
I AGREE WITH TREY.
HOW DID THAT INFORMATION HAD TO
GET OUT FROM ONE OF THESE THAT
UNMASKED OR  SOMEONE THEY GAVE
IT TO.
IT’S AMAZING, TO LOOK AT HOW THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA TREATS THIS
PRESIDENT.
THEY TREAT HIM AS IF HE WAS
DIFFERENT.
THEY BELIEVE ANYTHING IF HE WAS
ACCUSED OF COLLUSION OR  ACCUSED
OF DOING ANYTHING ELSE WITH THE
RUSSIANS BUT YET WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ONES THEY THINK ARE
THE GREATEST IN THE WORLD, THE
SUPER HEROS THAT THEY
THOUGHT REALLY NOTHING BUT A
CORRUPT BUNCH OF, YOU KNOW, THUG
S GOING AROUND IT
LOOKS LIKE NOW BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE EVERYTHING THEY SAY BUT
THIS GOES BACK, YOU KNOW, WAY
PAST THIS , FROM THE CLINTON E
MALL SCANDAL INTO THE
DISCUSSION OF RUSSIA AND SO
WHAT I WANT TO SEE HAPPEN IS
HOLD EMPLOYEE ACCOUNTABLE.
SOMEHOW THIS INFORMATION GOT OUT
WE NOW KNOW WHO UNMASKED, LET’S
START HAVING THE INVESTIGATION
AND DURHAM IS DOING THAT BUT
THERE NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY
BECAUSE HOW CAN THAT NOT HAPPEN
TO YOU AND ME?
MARIA: THROUGHOUT THIS , LET’S
NOT FORGET THEY MISSED THE REAL
BAD ACTOR AND THAT’S CHINA.
WHILE YOURSELF AND SOME
COLLEAGUES WERE INVESTIGATING
CHINA’S MOVES LIKE DEVON NUNES
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
WE’VE REPORTED THAT CONGRESSMAN
GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU, SIR.
WE’LL BE WATCHING YOUR